i'm not gonna lie to you and tell you
that i'm eating healthy genie mai is
eating for two and she's craving it all
i kind of love it on tuesday the real
co-host who's expecting her first child
with husband jeezy shared this video via
instagram story dishing on her pregnancy
cravings i'm not gonna lie to you and
tell you that i'm eating healthy
i crave random everything so here is a
sicilian pizza with extra everything
and inside a ranch
toasted fresh out of my air fryer as for
what she washes it down with i've never
craved milk ever but ever since baby j
all of a sudden i want specifically
whole milk i don't really care if you
think it looks gross but it tastes
straight from the cow's teat jeannie
first announced her pregnancy on monday
during the season 8 premiere of the reel
i am pregnant
[Applause]
and since her big reveal the talk show
host has been very open about her
pregnancy journey even taking fans
inside her doctor's appointment for a
glucose test so what's this test
supposed to do it's gonna check your um
cbc to make sure you're not anemic and
your glucose to make sure you're not on
gestational diabetic
and hopefully you're not and check this
out here's genie and jeezy doing an
at-home ultrasound so they can listen to
their baby's heartbeat
[Music]
the tv personality has also been very
candid about her love life i love
quality conversations i love
intimacy um i love you know thoughtful
presence with one another so this is a
dream for me jeannie and her husband
rapper jeezy tied the knot in march
after over two years of dating and in
june jeannie told et how getting married
has changed their dynamic married life
feels 1 000 different than when we were
dating in the greatest way we want to
feel trusted we want to feel loved we
want to feel safe we want to feel
cuddles we want to feel you know the
romance we want to feel dating want to
be hot and heavy with sex like you want
all those things so the fact that i'm
doing that with a partner that is
like-minded with me is the best part of
my life